je ma pierre jammes à l'eau
l'élève de 6e année qui est ici à
l'académie saint louis
je suis passionné de sequins j'adore mon
petit york filmer deux thomas darracq
mon plus grand rêve est de devenir
professionnel dans le domaine de la
santé
saviez vous qu'il existe des cowboys de
laboratoire dans ma présentation
j'expliquerai en quoi consiste à quoi
elle ressemble qui les ont inventés et
quelles sont leurs principales qualités
bonjour savez vous qu'il existe des
hamburgers de laboratoire moi non
jusqu'à ce que je me réveille un matin
il décide d'aller lire la presse plus la
page et intitulé burger de laboratoire
ceci m'a tout de suite intéressé donc
j'ai décidé de faire mon exposé sur ce
sujet les gens qui l'ont inventé sont
des scientifiques néerlandais
ils ont déjà fait l'expérience il ya
environ cinq ans vers 2010 2011
mais les juges qui ont goûté disait
qu'il y avait peu de goût
le seul but qu'il y avait été très chaud
donc les scientifiques ont dit qu ils
retravailleraient sur ce si on regarde
devrait être prêt dans corps environ 5 1
ce que je trouve quand même assez long
mais en même temps c'est normal car ils
doivent le fabriquer en deux grandes
quantités les apparences de centre
gauche el en vigueur et la boulette de
son bonheur est beaucoup plus petit et
plus minces
elle est plus rose et il ya quelques
flamands qui départ tu n'es pas très
appétissant
en tout cas moi j'aimerais pas vraiment
sans manger 1 comment elles fabriquent
leurs hamburgers
donc ils mettent tous les ingrédients
dans un gros bol dans les usines
ensuite les mélanges et les écrans par
la suite les mettre dans des petits
contenants et avec un noir marque la
date et l'heure fabriqué pour cana de
journée après plus les sortir du
réfrigérateur et les amener dans un
laboratoire pour qu'ils puissent les
analyser à être sûr qu'il nie
aucune bactérie pour qu'on puisse les
manger avec aucun danger jeu certains
cas peut beaucoup de personnes dans
cette salle se pose la caisse cette
question c'est quoi la différence entre
un beau gars normal dans le regard de
laboratoire et bien aujourd'hui je vais
vous l'expliquer le hamburger normale et
est constitué de plusieurs morceaux de
viande par exemple qu'on dit que dans un
morceau de viande
il y a cinq cellules de viande est bien
avec les hamburgers de laboratoire dont
nous pouvons le consommer avec des
cellules de viande dont nous pourrions
prendre seulement cinq morceaux de
viande et le consommer donc je trouve ça
beaucoup plus écologique quentin kimou
car nous en serions beaucoup moins et je
trouve que les animaux c'est très
important dans notre milieu de vie et en
même temps c'est ce qui explique le
manque de protéines et des calories dans
son programme donc nous devrions le
manger avec un accompagnement comme une
poussine des frites pour être sûr
d'avoir de l'énergie après
comment nous pourrions le faire cuire
nous pour factures barbecue au four mais
ce qui est préférable c'est au micro
ondes
selon heureux car le goût est et reste
et c'est meilleur
donc merci j'espère que quand les
hamburgers sortiront en magasin ou
restez vous oserez aller goûter même si
les apparences sont pas très bonnes